having gone through the experience
meeting Jen going to this pitch fest
what advice could you give other
screenwriters on meeting a filmmaker and
pitching their script you know it's no
different than being a photographer or a
director you don't have an opportunity
to explain yourself you see there on the
page or it's not on the page now if I
had met Jen and she was gone unquote
difficult just that the get-go I
probably would have never even read the
script you know so I think having a
little bit of communication skills as a
gift in that regard I also think you
know stereotypically I'm not I'm not
like the stereotype I'm open to
collaborating and if you find out right
at the beginning that the person isn't
here's a great example a woman who
Bethany again found me a wonderful
script about bigotry and the challenge
of working with skinheads and it was a
really really well-written movie it was
also a play and I had wished in
hindsight that I didn't spend an hour on
the phone with the writer when they said
all one thing I forgot to tell you is I
have to direct this myself so I felt you
know that that was something that should
have come out in the first 10 seconds
because to me you know it's not uncommon
for a screenwriter to say I don't want
anybody else to direct this but me I
only produce movies that I direct and
the outcome of it is is that you know
I've learned that lesson that huh right
so then if that is a requirement or
special requirements like I want very
little edits done right get that out
right away I would pass yeah I mean it's
just not worth it there's too many the
the independent film business is so
convoluted with waste and waste and then
when you finally get to execution here's
a wonderful example my other producer
well Newman who helped produce this
movie
he was like you know the not just an
incredible collaborator to this movie
but he was the hatchet man in a positive
way he would come in and say no
disrespect to Jen's material but she's
got 56 characters and he knew right away
bingo that that was going to translate
into a portion of the budget that was
disproportionate with what we had and
what does that mean in English only
affordable amount of characters we could
have in his opinion was between 20 and
25 characters and I know that sounds
crazy but any independent filmmakers
gonna come in front of the same moment
that I came in front of when you go do
you really need that character to walk
in the door go hey you got a phone call
that character is a SAG talking actor
and that's gonna cost you X amount of
dollars and you put 40 more of those in
the movie and you've made a movie that
you're not going to be able to afford
and it's crazy and you know I know that
you're interviewing me about creativity
but if you can get this stuff off the
table before you start talking
creativity you'll have you know in my
opinion a more controllable project
you